on se dépêche on se dépêche et pourquoi
vous partez de se mettre dans le
meilleur camp de vacances du monde parce
qu'il ya une célébrité
moi je pensais un truc comme parce qu'on
s'adore tous ou après qu'un peu un peu
oui car
j'ai obtenu mes amis vous 2nde les boues
téléphone votre nourriture et vos
appareils connectés c'est que deux
semaines mais sacha ne le sait pas sacha
et ton téléphone
cette année le camp jallow l'oeil qui a
été choisi pour une opportunité très
spécial et tout de suite pour vous en
dire plus ce monsieur comme
ici sera réalisé la toute première
production de la reine des neiges
[Applaudissements]
on va passer le meilleur des équipes
c'est mon premier compris ses parts dans
la chambre où est-ce qu'on reste groupe
premier petit ami je viens de me rendre
compte que vous alliez passer tous les
coller ensemble la première fois que je
peux vraiment espérer décrocher le
premier rôle le temps est venu de vous
présenter notre metteur en scène mr
x 15 mm je crois que j'ai repris remue
tes plus beaux atouts casuel
[Musique]
tout ce qui retient mon attention ce
sont les auditions pour le moment c'est
quoi le nom des deux gars principaux
dans la reine des neiges l'un d'eux
s'est dirais que c'est carrie aucun
d'eux ne s'appelle gary cette fois tu
pourras pas te la joie l'az efron
que je peux t'assurer sait que le
meilleur est à venir
[Musique]
et ça va les voiles certes j'ai
l'impression que ces dernières années
ont aidés à nous préparer pour un super
truc
personne ne pourra cacher notre parfaite
et et à tous les deux
oh
les enjeux de ces auditions n'ont jamais
été aussi haut
et je vais le dire mais son jeu n'ont
jamais été aussi haut
[Musique]